Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Have a look at these beautiful images.
Representing these materials that you see
here takes more than 25 gigabytes of storage.
You could store several feature-length movies
on your hard drive using the same amount of
storage.
And this technique is able to compress all
this 25 gigabytes into 45 megabytes without
introducing any significant perceptible difference!
That is close to a whopping 500 times more
efficient representation.
This improved representation not only helps
easing the storage requirements of these assets,
but it is also makes the rendering times,
or in other words, the process of creating
these images via light simulation programs
typically more than twice as fast to process.
That is a ton of money and time saved for
the artists.
An important keyword in this piece of work
is anisotropic scattering.
So what does that mean exactly?
The scattering part means that we have to
imagine these materials not as a surface,
but as a volume in which rays of light bounce
around and get absorbed.
If we render a piece cloth made of velvet,
twill, or a similar material, there are lots
of microscopic differences in the surface,
so much so, that it is insufficient to treat
them as a solid surface, such as wood or metals.
We have to think about them as volumes.
This is the scattering part.
The anisotropy means that light can scatter
unevenly in this medium, these rays don't
bounce around in all directions with equal
probability.
This means that there is significant forward
and backward scattering in these media, making
it even more difficult to create more optimized
algorithms that simplify these scattering
equations.
If you look below here, you'll see these colorful
images that researchers like to call difference
images.
It basically means that we create one image
with the perfectly accurate technique as a
reference.
As expected, this reference image probably
takes forever to compute, but is important
to have as a yardstick.
Then, we compute one image with the proposed
technique that is usually significantly faster.
So we have these two images, and sometimes,
the differences are so difficult to see, we
no way of knowing where the inaccuracies are.
So what we do is subtract the two images from
each other, and assign a color coding for
the differences.
As the error may be spatially varying, this
is super useful because we can recognize exactly
where the information is lost.
The angrier the colors are, the higher the
error is in a given region.
As you can see, the proposed technique is
significantly more accurate in representing
this medium than a naive method using the
same amount of storage.
This paper is extraordinarily well written.
It is one of the finest pieces of craftsmanship
I've come along in long while.
And yes, it is a crime not having a look at
it.
Also, if you liked this episode, make sure
to subscribe to the series and check out our
other videos.
We have more than 150 episodes for you, ready
to go right now!
You'll love it, and there will be lots of
fun to be had.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!